what's going on y'all this is Rob
[Music]
man my son okay uh so we gotta talk
about Miss Marvel the the season okay we
gotta do the review whatever who cares
so a girl gets Powers you know and the
white government Shake is evil and
Against All Odds he saves the day roll
credits okay so let's talk about the big
thing from the ending of the episode The
Big Thing from the ending of the episode
okay
okay
mutants all right now here's the here's
the thing I was a little worried at
first right I was a little word at first
because I was afraid Bruno was going to
be like you know I was looking at your
jeans Miss Marvel because I'm a weirdo
that's what I do it's how I Court girls
like hey I like you girl so I tested
your jeans so uh so he's like you know I
ran over your jeans and there's
something off about him and I thought he
was going to be like something inhuman
and I was gonna be like no because
nobody wants the Inhumans then humans
don't even want the Inhumans man like if
you don't believe me check this out
there was a story that was written
during John the victims Avengers The New
Avengers son oh my God there's a story
that was written during that story
called infinity and Black Bolt detonated
the terrigen bomb when he tried to beat
Thanos and got his ass whooped because
Black Bolt sucks and and all these
people across the world who were
Inhumans started waking up and the
inhuman royal family was like hey do you
guys want to come hang out with us and
they were like nope and we're gonna go
hang out with the X-Men and that's
exactly what they did so when Bruno came
out and he was like there's like a
mutation there then they played the
X-Men music I was like man it was man
let me tell you something is
it was amazing okay so look so here's
here's the thing here's the thing right
this this I mean this opens up so many
possibilities because as soon as I saw
this I was like man the possibilities
are endless sun because all these kids
because like I started thinking about
all the crazy things that have happened
in comics that can happen in the MCU now
like oh my God Franklin Richards dude
Franco okay so I started thinking about
that and I was like man imagine seeing
Franklin rich in the MCU let me tell you
something man all the stuff y'all have
seen in the movie so far don't it
doesn't it doesn't matter man Franklin
Richards dude's a beast so check this
out there's a story during Jonathan
hickory's Fantastic Four run man this is
the craziest story ever so Franklin
Richards as a kid gets his powers woken
up by his adult self or something that's
gonna happen you don't know what it is
until you get to the end of the story
because John and John and Hickman takes
forever to make make sense so like at
the end of the story these mad
celestials from an alternate reality
show up in the universe because Reed
Richards was was screwing stuff up and
literally Franklin Richards from the
future comes to the past and takes the
power of his younger self and resurrects
Galactus from the dead it's like the
most Beast moment ever so like so so
literally like Galactus was defeated by
the by the mat celestials he's basically
dead and then like Franklin he takes
about his younger self and he's just
like to me my Galactus like Resurrection
so it's just like damn all right so then
so then the celestials try to fight
Galactus and Franklin Richards as a team
up
they were not prepared and that's that's
the thing man that's the kind of stuff
you get because frankly Richards is a
mutant and mutants are on the whole more
powerful than everybody else they're the
most broken ass group of superheroes
ever right if superheroes were a gun
from video games they'd be the golden
gun from like the original golden eye or
the Famas from Black Ops one they were
just ridiculously overpowered you know
what I mean like it's it's crazy some of
the stuff that they can do so my thought
is okay cool so come on Khan is
basically a mutant here sure that's
that's the whole base behind her jeans
but that's that's a big statement that
he made that Bruno made because when it
comes to mutants in Marvel Comics one of
the things to know is that it's not
their genes that are that are adjusted
it's an X Gene right it's a singular
Gene in their body that activates
usually during puberty but can also be
done at moments of high duress and then
that basically leads to them developing
Powers right now sometimes they they
manifest really really early like in the
case of Hope Summers the the first
mutant born after the events of House of
M her powers activated when she was a
baby right so it's just kind of like
okay that's really crazy but uh and then
you have the whole story where like
cable took her into the future and it
was nuts and then she became new host of
The Phoenix force and Avengers versus
X-men and wrecked everybody Hope Summers
is ridiculously op she has the powers to
copy the powers of everyone she sees and
there's no limit to the number of powers
she can copy and she can use them
endlessly she's like Peter Petrelli from
Heroes so so this so that right there
right like just levels of power get
crazy when you talk about mutants now
for those of you guys who don't know
anything about the history of Newton's
in Marvel Comics this one things get
really really cool right one thing's
really really cool and if it's imperfect
with the MCU although I don't know how
they're going to do it with a Celestial
so the way this worked is in the early
days on Earth you basically had a group
called the Wonders right which are
basically the missing link between like
primeape man and Modern Man and there
weren't a ton of them there were just
some of them and you saw had like a
whole bunch of humans or you know
Baseline humans whatever running around
the world anyway what ended up happening
is the celestial showed up on Earth and
threw some weird stuff that they're
never going to do in the MCU you ended
up basically seeing the the Wonders
gathered together by these celestials
and the celestials started experimenting
on their genes now one third of that
group went on to become deviants we
already know where they originate from
in the MCU so that doesn't apply here
the second group became the eternals we
know where they originate so that
doesn't apply here and the third group
had their genes modified so that at some
future point in time those genes would
start to activate now Marvel used that
as an explanation one to explain where
mutants come from but two how it is that
somebody like Steve Rogers could be
exposed to like all these crazy ass
forms of radiation and become Captain
America instead of just a giant mass of
tumors so so that's that's what Marvel
Comics does right now how they're going
to do that in the MCU I'm not entirely
sure because what it sounds like is
maybe it's just an evolved state right
like quite literally the next stage of
human evolution because that's how it
always was when it came to mutants in
the MC I'm sorry in the comics is
mutants were considered the next stage
of human Evolution even though mutants
had artificially had their genes
Modified by Celestial so they weren't a
true evolutionary process kind of but
not really but I feel like the MCU would
actually adapt that right that like
Kamala Khan and people like her are just
the next stage in human evolution right
genes have just modified or evolved or
whatever it is and suddenly people are
developing natural Powers but the big
thing about this is that the the
difference between like mutants and say
for example like the Inhumans is that
one and humans sucking mutants don't and
two there's a limitless number of powers
that mutants can have right there's no
limit there so mutants can have powers
ranging from like telepathy Telekinesis
the ability to alter reality on a
universal scale like quite literally
just altering reality with no definitive
limit like uh what is it um Clyde
wincham right the Marquee of death that
guy had the power he was wiping out
whole universes with a wave of his hand
and that guy was a mutant right that's
the kind of power that you're talking
about here so if you can imagine it they
could have it but what's so cool about
this right isn't even necessarily the
mutinism ourselves it's the villains
right like William Striker so William
Striker is like the best villain ever
when it comes to mutants and Marvel
Comics like the biggest issue that you
had was like in in the the X-Men movies
which were asked William William Striker
was like a military guy and it kind of
makes sense that they would do that
because in the comics he's like this
religious fundamentalist who thinks it's
his mission from God to kill mutants so
if Fox had like done that like hey guys
here's William Striker he's some crazy
ass Pastor that wants to kill mutants
did like 80 percent of white folks would
be pissed so like obviously they weren't
gonna do that but the thing here is like
in the MCU they can get away with it man
because like who's gonna not watch it
right like who's gonna who's like like
any like the people are gonna protest it
and then be left out of the conversation
and go see it anyway so like there's
characters like William Striker who are
cool like William Striker is one of the
best villains ever when it comes to
mutants in Marvel Comics right there's
Magneto people like that but the long
and short the point that I'm making here
and this great big huge long ass rant
that I'm going on is is the introduction
of mutants into the MCU it really really
is a slow process right they really are
staging this as a slow process and that
makes the most sense right it makes the
most sense they would make it this slow
gradual process instead of doing it
right off the bat I still say they
should originate this or at least the
discovery of it with uh with like
Wolverine right like they should still
do that they're like Wolverine was
basically like he was a mutant whose
Gene was discovered by like Hydra when
it was initially taking over Shield
because Hydra was trying to create more
Captain America's in secret and that led
to them basically learning about like
the mutant Gene and everything because I
have to believe that Bruno is not the
only person who knows about this and I
think there's a lot of other
organizations who are aware of it and
potentially trying to track them down
but whatever the case happens to be man
like this is this is a ridiculously
amazing development for Kamala Khan
because I never agreed with the idea of
her being an inhuman I never liked that
right I mean her character was cool she
had some cool stories but I never liked
her being an inhuman because I felt like
it was just a hugely missed opportunity
to roll her into the X-Men where she
would have been a lot more effective and
a lot more interesting such a it is
right she was on Champions which was a
really really good comic and stuff like
that but I'm excited about this right
this is a hugely exciting moment and
that's how I think we're going to start
seeing mutants rolled into the MCU from
this point going forward until we get
the full-on introduction of the X-Men is
that it's gonna be people by whatever
Manner and whatever means something
happens and then it's just like this
person has a genetic mutation right like
this person has like some kind of gene
in their body or at least the
modification of their genes and that's
what's leading them to become who they
are because with the nature of the
celestials in the MCU there's nothing to
indicate that they're responsible for
the creation of mutants in the first
place right because it wasn't it wasn't
as though you know powers on Earth
originated from the celestials grand
experiment they created the deviants and
the eternals out there in space
somewhere right it's like robots
basically and that's essentially all
it's been so there's no reason to
believe that celestials are involved
here it's just peoples whose genes
people whose genes are modified and
those who have powers now the big
question that I would ask here is how
far reaching is this right how far
reaching does this go I mean you're
literally talking about like damage
control trying to find people with power
so maybe damage control knows and maybe
there's like instances out there where
like his powers are activating and like
no one knows what's going on or how to
control it like that's what happened
with Cyclops his powers if I remember
correctly his power I think what maybe
it was in the movie or something like
that but like his power is activated in
a classroom right like when it came to
Jean Gray her powers activated and she
couldn't control the telepathic thoughts
of everybody around her and was slowly
going insane until Xavier found her so
like it was it was like a lot of those
those little things right in the MCU I
could see that being the case the way
they build up to it is more of a
background thing right like some TV blip
or something like that where it's like
and in other news today another super
powered being has done this or that or
something like that and no one knows how
to explain this sudden rise of people
that have superpowers and that's it
right it's like a 10 second news blip in
the background of a show and that's it
right I feel like that'd be a great way
to do that so let me know what you guys
think down in the comment section I mean
okay so overall Miss Marvel yeah great
show cool I had a great time watching it
was fun whatever but uh thank you guys
for watching and I will catch you all
later peace